on today's episode of yang speaks we're
talking about carly's trip to miami hack
week we are talking about
andrew cuomo resigning but most
importantly
we're talking deep fakes on yang speaks
today so
welcome back everybody glad you've tuned
in carly welcome back from miami
how is your sunburn
because this has been an adventure
in the household here
yeah my sunburn is
has been excruciating though i will say
the internet has provided a lot of
relief in the sense that i feel like i
know what the trajectory of a sunburn is
so i've now learned that 48 days 48
hours post sunburn is
the worst so i'm now kind of over the
hump
and but yeah i like basically couldn't
wear a shirt yesterday not too if you
approve but if you've ever had it that
bad sunburn guys it's horrendous i had
it in college once where like it was
just itching and you're going nuts uh
the best thing i could tell you i had a
buddy of mine who is who served in iraq
who got
sunburned so severely and did not have
any aloe the key is aloe and anything
you'd find in that realm but if you
don't have that
cold shower no soap
cold ice cold shower cool down the skin
big time uh don't use any soap or
anything and then aloe if you can get it
but cold shower helps especially right
after um
so at least that's his tip it worked for
me we got burnt real bad and we just
took massively cold that's a fun spin on
the graduation speed speech right like
there's a famous graduation speech
that's like don't forget the sunscreen
and we can update it and be like but if
you do but if you do take a cold shower
i don't know what speech that is but
that sounds fun um
anyway you met some really cool people
two of them were gonna have on this
podcast um
what did you what's your big takeaway
from going down to miami's miami's
recruiting crypto engineers so they had
a hack week what's your takeaway carl
my takeaway is
i love nerds
and i love spending time with them and
then i think
it has only
re-solidified my commitment to this
world of blockchain crypto
the future i think this is a really
awesome
group of people and i would bet on them
any day of the week and i am betting on
them and it's going quite well thus far
so that's true
um
so before we get in there let's do a
couple of things i think are worth
talking about quickly um
big news that happened today we're
recording this on august tuesday august
10th you're hearing this on thursday the
12th um or around then
governor andrew cuomo
has officially resigned
uh governor of new york here here's my
quick hot take my rationally average a
take uh here
okay
i
on a human level
there are some conservative values like
limited government and
like making it easier to do business
that i align with um and i think i've
made that somewhat clear on this podcast
um but i'm a democrat because i believe
generally that the democrats are trying
to be the good guys and have empathy
and take care of our least fortunate
which is to me why the cuomo thing is
very frustrating
because it's the hypocrisy and you see
it across the democratic party a lot
so you're trying you're part of the good
guy you're saying you're a good guy
you're playing on the good guy team if
you will but then you're a [ __ ]
predator like what the hell and
on one end now anyone listening is like
well republicans are substantially worse
and i would agree generally speaking
or depend you know case by case but
generally speaking yes but
republicans in some ways uh own the fact
that they're [ __ ] like they don't
pretend to be someone they're not and
there's a certain odd amount of
respect i have for people that just own
their shittiness as opposed to
pretending being a wolf in sheep
clothing pretending to be a good guy
and then being a freaking predator and
which is why democratic hypocrisy
really really bothers me so um i don't
know what your thoughts are but that is
my
cuomo take of the day
yeah i i think i agree with that i think
it's really frustrating when you
have people on our own team who are
making us look bad uh and the other
thing is
i feel like we haven't made enough of
the
the
um
nursing home deaths like i feel like
that's something that the republicans
have hammered really hard and that was
like fox news's big talking point
but the democrats now are
are reckoning with the cuomo thing over
the women front but i don't feel like
we've reckoned enough with the fact that
like
for a while that to me felt like it was
worse than the women's scandal now
you've had more women come out it sort
of changed but like
for a while it was like
what like we're just gonna gloss over
this and you wanna talk about hypocrisy
i mean this was the dude who wrote the
book on like how to handle the covet
pandemic like
and i think that's that's also just part
of this takeaway is to think about
i mean i read an article what we're
being sold how's that sorry i read an
article or but i read an article in
glamour magazine or whatever it was like
in the beginning of the pandemic you
know talking about how cuomo is her
boyfriend like a whole like kind of
funny article about homosexual cuomo
yeah yeah i'm a homosexual exactly like
this like this dude was so propped up in
so many ways and at the time i remember
feeling like it was rhetoric over
substance it felt like
i'm not hearing enough about what
cuomo's actually doing i just hear that
people are really
turned on by
his briefings at the end of the night
because he can form a complete sentence
and trump
our president we were looking at the
time for strong leadership and for
in many ways he is a strong leader he is
a strong personality he is bold he is
decisive he is articulate he is calm in
a crisis all those things he's also a
predator he also appears to be a liar he
also appears not appears there's also
strong there's a strong evidence on that
he has a very hostile workplace and
people are terrified [ __ ] working for
him
i look you don't deserve these jobs
we don't
as people we should not be tolerating
this i'm glad he's resigning i'm glad
we're getting rid of him screw that guy
i feel i'm proud of all the women who
stood up and said something i'm ashamed
of all the people who let it go on for
probably decades it's [ __ ] up
um
there was this defense at least in the
beginning that's like all right he's
just kind of a creepier old guy like
generation gap a little touchy feely but
the reality is
yeah but the reports were pretty i read
the report they're pretty bad he's like
roping women up their shirt and
mentioning very creepy condom and when
there's smoke there's fire and it's 11
women all saying the same pattern of
behavior it's not one or two one-offs
it's not a crate you know there's you
take all these i believe you take these
all case by case
but we should believe women when they're
saying stuff in the sense that we should
listen um and understand why they're
saying something um and give them the
same air cover that men get but um or at
least platform to say things but and
this was pretty dark um so
it sucks to lose a strong quote unquote
strong democratic governor of our
biggest or one of our biggest states
being ours in the democratic party but
can't have this uh bad for the party bad
for the country bad for the women um bad
for him bet for everybody this sucks um
so sorry to start this pod off with
negative news but it's not funny best of
luck to kathy hoechel and very cool if
i'm pronouncing her last name right and
then uh and excited to have our best of
luck to new york state
female governor of new york state one
requirement for the new governor is that
they need to keep the buffalo bills in
new york and they need to let us build a
new stadium so that's all i really care
about um let's talk about the real
issues um
so before we dive in we have a really
fun conversation on
deep fakes which blew my freaking mind
um but the last thing i want to say
before we get to deep fix is um
was checking out for those you've been
listening carly made a call on something
uh nft a non-fungible token called a
gift goat that gary vaynerchuk is doing
and i went in and checked we didn't get
one because of some
logistical complications and they were
for sale for three eth when eat was at
let's call it eighteen hundred dollars
we were buying it for five eighths okay
five eve um
and i just went and peeped that price
and they are being sold online for 35
eth so um
that's a hundred grand uh that's a down
payment on a home um
i guess right um
or a whole bunch of things and so we're
pissed so hopefully i'll took our actual
carly's investment advice gift goats to
the moon um probably still going up damn
so i will i will also like my second
plug for v friends is i i do own two v
friends um not the gift goats but other
nfts from this overall drop and because
i'm a v friend holder i was keep giving
him more shifted an additional nft
something called an avistar for free
that i already have offers on for like
600 bucks so
the blogs are just
printing money i'm not trying to be a
jerk
but you know i've stopped doubting gift
goats to the moon anyway
um tell us about who we got coming on
carl
yeah i'm super excited about this so
when i was in miami for this hackathon
also if anybody wants to like learn more
about hackathons dm me i'm like very
nerdy into hackathons at this point um
and this was a really cool one so uh
i met a number of really cool people and
i had this awesome call-in card which is
co-hosting this podcast so when i found
people that i thought were special or
interesting you know i would i would
connect with them and ask them to come
on the show so we'll probably have a
couple more of these interviews but
these next two people they're super
impressive young folks who are at this
hackathon um both with backgrounds in ai
machine learning um and they're building
they built a very cool deep fake product
we can't get into the specifics of it
because they're in
like you say
raising money for it and so they like
are trying to keep it kind of stealth
but we were able to have a broader
conversation with them around deep fakes
and i can tell you they are legit
because i've seen the deep fake i saw
the deep vic they built over the course
of this week-long hackathon very cool
it is alex lazar and francesca callejos
so very excited to have them both on the
pod and talking to us about the future
23 year old babies who know more about
the future of the
tech and the world it was mind-blowing
deep fakes are terrifying and awesome
you guys are gonna love this tune in
deep fake conversation yang speaks right
now
[Music]
very excited to welcome alex lazar and
francesca callejas to yang speaks i met
these two in miami this past week during
miami hack week they were working on
some very cool stuff and they built a
deep fake of one of the miami hackathon
organizers and it was so cool i wanted
to have them on for a bigger
conversation about deep fakes the
technology where this might all be going
uh it's crazy so it's terrifying and
awesome
anything that's terrifying and awesome
is worth talking about
um
let's do this assuming no one knows
anything so
i guess i'll start with you alex because
you're nodding more passionately than
francesca or something personal
[Laughter]
but maybe all right you either have the
best answer but let me start with you uh
can you explain
let's say it's my mother she's in her
early 60s what a deep fake is
yeah sure so i mean i think the simplest
way to explain a deep fake is just like
the first term i would say it's
synthetic media it's not real it's like
you're creating some type of new media
and that media specifically is in which
a person uh in an existing image is
replaced by or a video is replaced by a
person or video from another video so
imagine like right now we were able to
swap your face zac onto carly's face and
it sounded like cuzak it moved like you
but it was still on like carly's body
and everything
so anything to add to that francesca
um no i think that was a really good
summary i think
i think the
main thing to hone in on is like it is
completely computer generated
synthetic video and even audio
does someone have to actually do it for
you to put a deep fake on top of it so
like does i have to say i have to do the
action or say the words or be on the
screen and then you layer on someone
else's face so it's real in some way but
not the real person doing it
it could go both ways so you could let's
say you had like carly's face but you
wanted your voice um and there are there
is a fake technology where we could get
carly to move her lips her eyes the
lighting and everything exactly but
it'll be your voice zach coming out oh
or advice
yeah
or there's even
yeah or there's even like the creepier
ones where you can kind of like
superimpose your face zach with your
movements directly onto carly
oh boy so but it does but it's not like
you can make carly do
anything you have to someone else has to
do it and then you can make it look like
carly did that thing is that
fair and does is the technology going to
a place where you can just make real
people look like you know no one has to
actually act it out um or
is that core of the tech
i think typically the way it works is
that basically like at a very high level
what we're doing is like sophisticatedly
in a sophisticated way we are overlaying
two images or videos on top of one
another and then you're taking the
components of it that you would
want and computer generating like kind
of the parts of it that weren't there to
begin with so like maybe movements that
weren't exactly made so like to make
your mouth look as though you were
saying
whatever carly was saying for example um
so
like at a high level the way the
technology works right now is like you
would need a background of
what you want the new superimposed layer
to look like so you would need some kind
of um yeah like actor in the background
or like creator in the background that
could be acting out the movements of
what you would want the like deep faked
version to do
and the technology is though getting to
a place i would say where it's like if
we would let's say zach uh created a
machine learning or ai model of your
voice
then and had some good video of you we
would be able to create a deep fake of
you saying whatever we wanted to say
exactly that's kind of like you kind of
said the next evolution and it's going
to get more and more
let's call it uh
ambiguous or empowering to the
coder if you will the engineer to make
people look like they're doing what we
want um
okay
whole bunch of questions carly you know
more about design dudes i'm just going
to ask that dumb question so first
things first are they easy to spot if
they're
fake or do they look and feel real like
what like um
like is it like you know like certain
experts can tell something's been
photoshopped um
is that this case for deep fakes or are
they like unrecognizable someone has to
like publicly say that's a deep fake
i would say there's like a two-part
answer to that there is like kind of an
ongoing
um like in kind of like the world of
like you know internet fakes just in
terms of like you know fake news and
there's kind of also like an education
process i would say going on in the
world of like people trying to identify
like deep fakes and that's such a big
question that's going on there's
actually been legislation that's been
introduced um i know darpa actually has
all the time like events where they have
people say like hey like we'll pay you
this is a crowd-sourced event we're
trying to figure out ways that a we can
identify deep fakes and b ways that we
could stop the spread of defeats if they
were to be identified so this is
something that's like constantly being
investigated and constantly uh being
looked into just because as you could
imagine like you guys are saying um if
we were to make deep fakes of you and
take over yang speaks i don't think that
would be good for anybody well if you
make me sound smarter and or better
looking i'm in if not that's a problem
um
okay this is oh my god okay so i'm
scarlett i'm just gonna keep happening
um
i have two use cases i want y'all's
opinions on one is wholesome and one's
kind of
weird and maybe a little dark um let's
start with the wholesome one is
hollywood so theoretically could i have
a bad actor a cheap actor
go in and shoot a movie and then i
deep fake leonardo dicaprio on him so i
have to i can pay for leo's like license
but i have to pay for his time and all
that other crap and save a bunch of
money is that that in the future
yeah that's actually a really
interesting use case because this has
been used in hollywood already um
there's like really previous technology
yeah so one of the way did you guys get
a chance to watch the irishman that just
came out on netflix
the one that came out a couple of years
ago the square movie or the
with robert de niro it's like the famous
movie yeah okay yeah oh yeah okay not
that whatever yeah
watching that movie
okay it's incredible
very long yeah so like five yeah
okay yeah it's it's a very long movie
yes um but what they did was that they
paid millions and millions of dollars to
come up with this de-aging technology so
that robert de niro looked like decades
younger in the film and al pacino um
so
by the way this movie isn't that old it
won the academy award last year so sorry
yes yes it's how long no it's it's not
that old yeah no but that that's why
they it was what they wanted was to see
like a young robert de niro in the film
rather than like
younger like today's day and age robert
de niro so they yeah so again so netflix
paid like millions and billions of
dollars for um this like sophisticated
technology that could de-age
some of these actors in the film
including al pacino robert de niro um
but um deep fakes were actually able to
do this so much better so they were
using this technology called vpx i think
something like that um but
it's definitely not sophisticated as
deep fake so what deep so some youtuber
came in and within seven days used this
open source technology so it was
entirely free and came up with a way to
de-age these same actors much better so
he like posted this video went viral
yeah it went viral because send me this
video we'll put in the link that's
awesome okay cool yeah i'll send it it
was so fascinating because people were
like oh this is so much better like when
netflix comes and uses i that this
youtuber's name is i fake they're like
when when youtube comes in and uses i
fake's version of the movie then i'll go
ahead and watch it again but this one's
so much better
um so there are already like some use
cases for doing this in hollywood which
is interesting but it's just i think
we're still a long ways to go from this
being like very widely adopted i think
like a use case that you mentioned like
like would leonardo dicaprio be okay
with his likeness being sold and not his
time like would that devalue his
his means as an actor because it
wouldn't be his acting at that point you
would be taking the acting of the like
lesser actor underneath him and just
like overlaying his face on there so i
think it like introduces a lot of
questions of like what do you actually
want from the actor or from from the
person who's being used as a deep fake
um and like like what do you actually
care to keep like is it true you can
make someone be a different type of
character right if they want you want
them to have longer hair you want them
to have uh different colors right in
some ways
it's the reverse of what you're saying
zach instead of buying a crappy actor
it's like you use something like a good
actor who maybe doesn't look the way you
want the the character to look and you
can superimpose a different look upon
they're going to fix all the british
actors teeth is what they're doing oh my
god
we have a long running joke because i
like british shows because i have a
theory that they are like less committed
to having to have only like super hot
actors in british
i fully agree with that they don't have
to look like movie stars i credit to my
mom this was actually her theory
originally and i think it's true so they
have i don't think it's theory i think
it's true fine very good actors because
they don't have to make them look like
supermodels all the time we love
something super hot we but we'd rather
have subpar acting and above average
look than the other way around right
we actually care about the craft okay
not that's not the point of this what
was your second use case so my second
use case is
very strange we could cut this out as
i'm comfortable but i think we keep it
might go for it second use case second
thing is pornography yeah and
in a world where
um
you can
i mean you get the same porn stars
plural if you want
do making themselves look like different
types of people and monetizing the same
um
the the their same actions to different
audiences because every important people
have their different preferences and and
fetishes or whatever it is and my
question that might the wholesome side
of me is like that sounds very
theoretically safer because i think the
one of the biggest challenges of porn
street is very young women like um like
regretting you know making that career
choice
um or you don't you might you can do
this you know later in life or when
you're older and that sort of thing but
um the other one is that you could put
you know an innocent the girl next door
or a teacher or whoever it is in the
body of a porn star and share that
virally and that's that's horrific so
i mean thoughts on the and not only
pornography i guess but like the dark
side of this too
yeah yeah i mean
i i know
there was during my research while i was
looking into this like for this stuff um
i did come across like specifically
there was one big incident of something
exactly almost like you're talking about
that happened which which kind of like
spurred this whole conversation which
there was this technology or software
that came out it was um i don't know i
feel embarrassed so it's called deep
nude um
and it was actually like a paid for
application that used um this same
technology that's used to make deep
fakes where you could upload a picture
of anybody you wanted and it would
generate them without clips
um and that was quickly like within i
don't know how i love that some coder
was like this is the coolest application
this is the best way to apply this well
i i i i don't even know if that's what
they thought but the thing is like in
kind of like the whole thing surrounding
deep fakes which i think gets everyone
so worried and it's like the perfect
example might be pornography is that
it's just getting a little too easy it's
getting to that point where it's like
you know like there's so many youtubers
like almost to that last example that
you said where it's like they're able to
just make these things almost
which again which years ago or maybe
decades ago which should have taken
millions if not like entire research
agencies from countries to develop so
maybe within a week or two and somebody
in their basement yeah
exactly
exactly and another thing to add here is
that it like for everyone that's making
technology that um yeah that has good
use cases like like the first wholesome
use case that you mentioned like there's
always going to be someone that can use
that perniciously and that was like
it is already happening like alex
mentioned at some point they did i think
back in like 2018 they did an audit of
like deep fakes out like in the wilds
web and it was something like 95 of them
were being used for pornography
at first
so pornography industry is usually
cutting edge tech they uh it's a lot of
money they can take risks um
endless market anyway sorry um
um
this is
it's one of the things about the
internet i don't know if you guys have
seen the um the social dilemma with with
tristan harris it was on netflix but it
was i mean he's been he's been a guest
on the pod but he says something so
fascinating he's like the this
technology and his advancing technology
are both
utopia and dystopia at the same time
where it's
it's literally heaven where you can do
the most amazing wholesome incredible
things with the tech and you can have
the exact
same
like
you know as awesome as it is it's
equally as terrible um yeah
and
you guys on the cutting edge of that go
ahead carly
okay so so talk to us about some other
interesting use cases for this where is
this all going
mm-hmm outside of what zach and i can
even imagine so so i think what's really
important to realize is that like the
deep fake technology is kind of built on
many other ai and machine learning
models and those things like this is
just the product of those models like
specifically auto encoders and gans
which stands for general adversary
generative adversarial networks um long
story short
those both of those models combined are
what are commonly used to make all the
deep fakes that you see today um and
what they're basically doing at the end
of the day
is trying to generate something that is
real and looks realistic
um and one of the big areas where that
actually comes into place is two things
one it can be used a lot in ai for like
self-driving cars or image recognition
where it's like are we trying to
determine if this traffic light is real
or if it's not i think there's actually
a bug recently in the tesla software on
when there's like a full moon recently
where i think every tesla was detecting
it as like a red light or something um
and that was like you know a perfect
example of this where it's like you know
it's maybe it's sending all the
information that the car is recognizing
oh it's giving me all the data that i
think it's a light i'm giving all the
data that i should be telling my person
the car that's a light but the same
technology that's used to almost
generate deep fakes um is used to verify
if this is real or not another common
example that it's used is for drug
discovery where it's like they actually
will uh in
model like uh in a molecular models uh
on computers like pick and remove by
hand like different molecules and see
what the computer generates and they've
actually like verified some of these
drugs on mice to see if they work or not
so drug discovery is in prescription
drugs not as in we're discovering heroin
in somebody's locker no no no no
exactly
like different permutations like how
they would work and not
way more
wholesome yeah there's a there's a big
overlap between the technology that deep
fakes use and like the power of computer
vision and that's the technology that
alex was talking about so computer
vision is what powers like tesla's
self-driving cars that they can identify
what's on the road as a road as a street
light as a pedestrian as another car
coming um you can use this to like um to
like take an image and do some really
interesting like analysis of what's
going on in the images that was actually
one of the other hack week projects that
was really cool they were doing like a
like a modern day theranose
um but using computer vision it wasn't
based on chemistry they were taking i
think
they could probably talk more about the
technology but they were like taking an
image of like the red blood cell counts
and using that to determine um yeah what
kind of diseases an individual can have
so like there's a lot of power behind
like the computer vision technology and
deep fake is just like one interesting
use case in which um i think the reason
why people are so fascinated by it is
because it does like tread the line
between like uncanny valley and like
reality perfect
and it's scary and it'll be this will be
like the tip of the sword i think
politically over time what let me ask
this like
is there a world so you talked about the
beginning where you're layering two
videos over right so you need a real and
then you need the fake and then you you
know that's a thing
um is there a world where the real is a
video game or you have zach's video game
character which our graphics are getting
better and better let's say i look close
to zach and you make him up and then you
layer on a real zack on on top so then
you actually could make me do literally
anything um without a real actor is that
where this could be going i imagine yes
but i don't know
yeah definitely no that's like a very
solid use case for it because you would
in this case you would use the
animations from the video game to be the
underlying um technology or the
underlying actor that you can overlay
this technology on top of which um
yeah i think that there are use cases in
this already like going back to the like
pernicious use cases like i think they
are already doing stuff like this with
pornography
so like it does like yeah there's a
there's a lot of ways in which you could
already leverage that technology for
deep fakes i think it's just not like
out in the wild yet for like more
wholesome use cases
i keep going back to hollywood where
it's like why are pixar movies so good
because
they can edit them forever to make them
perfect right and they have lower margin
or higher margin excuse me like lower
costs um
so there's a world where you can have
all the benefits of a pixar movie where
you can perfect it and cut your cost but
then make it look completely real with
famous actors um
and i'm saying this out loud holy [ __ ]
this is gonna be cool but i i think i
think francesca's point is right which
is that these actors aren't going to
agree to this and there does feel like
there's there will be i think i disagree
i think there'll be money in it like
like a leo maybe not but like an
up-and-comer sure um
one common thing maybe that we're not
considering what about dead actors yeah
using their like using their likeness
like you know that's even already been
done a little bit like in star wars with
like
don't you think psychologically the
experience is a user and maybe we'll get
over this hurdle eventually but like is
totally different like why am i i don't
want to watch a movie where it's all
it's all fake like zach would you watch
the buffalo bills the way you typically
do if like it wasn't actually any of the
real i don't know it just i think that's
different but like i loved robin
williams would i love to see him again
in a new movie hell yeah even though
it's not him acting it would be like his
ethos and energy and still just as funny
i think there'll be plenty of people
that want to see it i mean look if it's
not is funny you don't watch it but if
you do it well it would be good
francesco sorry
well what if you were able to capture
robin williams personality enough
that it was his humor and it was like
you the voice would be easy because
there's so many movies with his voice
and the acting would be easy because
there's so many
there's already so many images of him
out there like i i guess the the
question there would be like the
underlying actor like would we be able
to use like some of his old videos as
underlying actors so that we can even
we can even use like him to like
motivate his new film so i will say
there was another interesting deep fake
project at miami hack week and it was
this
gentleman i don't know even what his day
job is but he does a lot on tick tock so
he's eight hundred thousand tick tock
followers his day job is tick tock come
on i don't i don't i don't think it
talks about i don't know
[Laughter]
and so bang's core policy to running for
mayor
according to the press okay sorry
okay so you didn't see this we got a lot
of [ __ ] for it okay nearly a million he
had nearly a million tick tock followers
and he basically built a deep fake of
himself
that would go live on his tick tock
channel for like he went live for 11
hours straight but it was his deep fake
going live and he gained 10 000
followers on tick tock by having his
deep fake of himself go live on his own
channel and he said he came to this
because he was seeing that when he would
go live people would just ask the same
questions over and over again it was
like how are you like what's up like
what are you up to what'd you have for
breakfast
so we just got to the point where he's
able to create enough answers to those
that he then was able to to make himself
go live gain a bunch of followers
without actually having to be there and
he took like a video of himself at a
party while he was theory going live on
tick tock but you know like it it's
really interesting some of those
kind of self-solving like creator
so
examples both vote for the both of you
like
one you're incredibly young and
impressive so when i was however old you
are 19 i was
i don't think you're quite
[Laughter]
also 23. you guys can drink okay cool
but still um
i wasn't doing what you're doing um
let me
so the more i like look into what's
coming out of pike future tech wise
my brain just always goes to the
this conclusion that we're inevitably
going to live in ready player one world
um or have that as an option
do you guys agree with that or is this
going to integrate into maybe more elon
musk is trying to build where like the
computer sync with our brain and that
the world is
the world the real world is a ready
player one environment that like is
connected deeply to technology or you
think we end up building this like
separate world
um
or we could like upload into matrix
style i don't know what do you what do
you think where does this go in your
mind
i would say that it's like i think kind
of like you know look at technology like
today and like the large landscape it's
like you know we're also like in a cool
place where like you know me and
francesco were like in like such a good
position where like we're able to like
go to like this hackathon and like kind
of like also then like go to school and
work on like kind of like this cutting
edge stuff um but at the end of the day
like you know there's still such a large
amount of like the world you know i
wouldn't i don't know what the
percentage would be that like you know
doesn't even know or doesn't even care
for i would say like what some of this
stuff is so i would always say that
there i always view it as like this
dichotomy that there's always like the
super far cutting edge like you know the
neural link the like deep fake this
crazy stuff and then there's like also
the people that you know are just this
doesn't really affect them and they
don't really care about it and i think
the future will be kind of just more of
that i always see it as this split kind
of continuing where it's like you know
there are some there are many people
that today that still don't even use
computers um and who's to say that like
you know that will ever change i mean
maybe there is a future where more and
more like we reach kind of like uh i
think there's like a word for it like in
like the in the terminator like the
equinox where it's like enough people
are now on the web and it's like we all
are in the singularity i think it's what
they call it or something um
but i think
in terms of that for a while we're still
gonna kind of see like a very large
split for the future until like we
reached that point you're sort of
describing like a worsening of i call it
like cultural inequality right like
there's inequality obviously in wealth
and income etc but there's a lot of
inequality that's connected to money but
in like how we're living our lives now
at this point in the world for sure
getting more severe and it sounds like
this is only going to
make it more and more severe
for sure for sure i agree 100
well i'll just say francesca where do
you think this is going you know what is
this what's the end game here
i i don't know that i fully agree with
alex actually because i think i think i
mean it's probably true that not the
entire world is going to adopt
technology we already know that that's
true like you said not every
civilization in society is online
um but it does seem as though we're
headed in a direction where at least the
united states like it like you know just
thinking about our nation like you know
my little brother's school is adopting
ipads already and he's he did the
starting in elementary school um so if
like technology's being more and more
adopted starting from an early age and
like the public school sector then most
people at least in the us i would say
would probably be comfortable with
technology i don't know that it's going
to happen
right away i think that people get
really scared when they see this kind of
technology and they think oh my gosh in
10 years everything is going to be
revolutionized by this and i think it'll
be a lot slower than that like a lot of
movies from the 90s and 80s predicted
that like in the 2020s we would already
have like flying cars and we'll be
hovering everyone would back for the
future
yeah exactly exactly and that's not the
case so i do think it'll be really slow
but i think that when we get to
what when maybe a hundred years down the
line or 150 years down the line things
will be a lot harder to i think we'll
have to answer the question of like
what's real and what isn't
a lot more than we do right now like
right now you can you know label a deep
fake as a deep fake and that's that but
what happens when people are like
like maybe half bionic creatures have a
neural link inside their brain and a lot
of a lot of even their thoughts are
computer generated or their emotions are
computer generated i think
i think
that that day might come
and i think then we'll have to answer a
lot of the questions about yeah what
exactly is reality how do we draw that
line it's a real question and i think
right now you have like the free markets
kind of running rip shot over society
when it comes to tech like we can do
anything there's no regulation generally
speaking
social media and the internet are
melting our children's and adults brains
um or uh melting is probably too
negative potentially depend like i don't
know it depends who you ask but
they are changing us um
people are even our english languages
people are learning to talk and
communicate with emojis you got a list
right um
so
i don't know but what i do know is you
guys are at the forefront of it i'm
excited to
watch your careers go i'm excited for
what you guys are building um so keep us
posted but thank you from the bottom of
our hearts for joining this was
mind-blowing and a little terrifying
mind-blowing more importantly
thank you so much for having us like i
said don't know if i ever get this
chance yang gang what's going on yes sir
yeah
baby
[Music]
all right folks that's our show thank
you for tuning in before you go one last
piece of news
i put at the end because not all of you
care about this but you should is that
josh allen
quarterback for the buffalo bills just
stein
a 250-plus million just stunned he's so
excited 250 million plus contract to
stay in buffalo through 2029.
folks
this is so exciting i cannot tell you
it's been 20 years i thought you told me
it was six years six year extension on
top of the next two now oh
if you are
i'm not expecting you to be this is
that's what i say
it's been 20 years been two decades and
the bills have been good they were good
in the 90s and they haven't had a
quarterback for 20 years i'm not
expecting you to love football i'm not
expecting you to give a [ __ ] about
zach's passion for the buffalo bills but
i will say this
josh allen is one of the coolest stories
in professional sports today this kid
was unrecruited did not got zero
scholarship offers to go to play
football in college went to junior
college still didn't get any offers got
one offer from the university of wyoming
went there tore it up got drafted in the
nfl by like dropped to seventh pick in
the nfl
by the buffalo bills he's so buffalo he
is a woman everyone doubted him
everybody nobody thought he was gonna
make a wonderful human being the
teammate teams love him people love him
he's a great guy
and he's gonna be in buffalo for a long
time and last season this is the second
time he voted
up and ready for
guys
i love sports because it's a way to
give so much of a [ __ ] and just care
passionately about something about
something you have no control over so
i'm asking you go on this buffalo bills
josh allen journey with me for the next
eight years you're not going to regret
it and when the bills with that super
bowl behind josh allen it's gonna be one
of the greatest stories all right that
already it already is one of my great
stories but it's gonna be probably the
best story
in nfl history and i am so freaking
excited so then i'll shut up tune in
next week we won't talk that much about
the buffalo bills uh we love you guys
have a great week see you next thursday
[Music]
[Music]
you